hey hey i'm mark norman we're in new
york city best city in the world
but now there's nobody here i got the
whole place to myself i can finally do
what i always wanted to do
let's live it up it's norman's landing
why didn't i buy that zoom stock
[Music]
[Applause]
slide them up
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i think we got it all right
we're entering chinatown
oh boy i better suit up
[Music]
i'm not going to waste it i always cut a
hole in the tip of my mask
just like my condoms
[Music]
just a little off the back please here's
my friend
yeah you know it's uh it's been a while
thank you
[Music]
guys said i don't see color i said well
i'm black he goes no you're not and i
went aha
[Music]
[Applause]
you